so Sal here at Khan Academy worldwide
headquarters and I'm excited to be here
with Barbara Oakley who's an expert on
learning and learning how to learn and
so Barbara let me just start with a
question that I'm sure that many of Khan
Academy users or young people around the
world frankly all people have faced
which is you're trying to learn
something and you're looking at a
textbook or teachers giving a lecture
and all of a sudden it's just not making
sense and you keep trying to pound your
head on it what's going on in the brain
at that time and and and is the only
option to just keep trying to power
forward oh no the last thing you want to
do is keep powering forward I mean
ultimately you want to do that but if
you're really stuck and you're very
frustrated as I used to get when I was
trying to study when I was growing up
the best thing to do is to back off and
get your mind completely off what you're
stuck on and I mean completely off so
either study something very different or
go out for a walk or just do something
that gets your mind off of it as soon as
you get your mind off it it turns out
that opens up a completely different set
of neural circuits it's the difference
between tasks positive or you're
focusing and task negative where you're
not focusing at all and these are this
alternate set of circuits is what allows
you to begin making sense of the stuff
that you've been struggling with so as
long as you're focusing on it you're
actually keeping yourself stuck because
you're not allowing these other neural
circuits to kind of kick into gear so
that's why people say back off when you
get frustrated I never understood that
before and now I do it's very powerful
so what you're saying is actually backs
up my experience I remember in college
when I used to take these you know these
kind of very difficult math proof
classes and these proofs the first time
you look at them I mean I don't know but
I got into a habit I kind of fell into
it of I would read the proofs and make
sure I understood or read what I was
trying to prove and make sure I
understood it and then I would go to
sleep
then I wake up in the next morning and
it was like I just kind of got out of
the work I delegated it to my brain and
it just happened and you're saying that
that actually is it's based in science
it's based really good in fact there's
some great research out that shows that
as you sleep at night that's when those
little dendritic spines will like
explode out and make those synaptic
connections and it happens when you're
sleeping so if you've learned you
studied focus during the day you go to
sleep at night that's when the neural
architecture is actually popping out in
and forming so that's why sleep can be
such an important part of learning and
how do you know this I mean have y'all
actually looked at do you have people
trying to learn something and then you
put them in an MRI how do you know well
at NYU has done some fantastic research
published in science and it it studies
what happens to neurons when you sleep
at night and often some of these studies
involve mice because we don't want to
dissect little living it's but it really
gives us a great understanding of how
that architecture is growing while we
sleep and there's another thing when you
go to sleep well during the day as the
day goes by you get this sort of little
toxic stuff that's coming out of your
cells so that's why at night you feel
kind of mentally fatigued but when you
go to sleep what happens is your brain
cells shrink this allows those metabolic
I mean the does sort of cerebral fluids
to wash away those toxins and that's why
in the morning you feel so much fresher
you don't want to go a night without
sleep or with a very small amount of
sleep because that can't wash those
toxins away and then the next day you're
working with a poison brain which isn't
a good idea so making this very tangible
if I have an exam coming up let's say
next week what would you based on what
you know and based what the science
tells us what would be the optimal
strategy and let's just say I don't know
much of what is covered on the exam
and a week from now well how would you
tell me to approach that don't sit there
and say I'm gonna do ten hours of
studying the day before the exam instead
say I'm going to take let's say you have
ten hours available parse that out do an
hour I want to have each day and each
day as you're learning that night when
you go to sleep you're making some more
connections the next night you've
studied some and you're making more
connections and as each day goes by
you're building a really solid set of
connections if you wait until the day
before and then clam your building very
poor connections because you only have
one night of sleep to actually do the
connections and sometimes it's even
worse I remember from college what most
students do is actually use that last
night of sleep to study those 10 hours
and then they go in without any sleep
often times sounds like the worst
possible thing it is and then what
sometimes happens is they'll come to me
and say I suffer from test anxiety and
actually test anxiety is very real some
people study really hard and they get
very nervous but other people use poor
study strategies and then they they
freeze on the test and it's because they
didn't actually learn the material well
and so they're because we don't teach
about how the brain learns very much
that's part of why people make these
kinds of sometimes tragic mistakes so if
this makes sense and I think even before
knowing about the science a lot of
students all of us intuitively know yes
I should probably start working on it
sooner I shouldn't do it last minute so
why do we as humans do that why do we
put it off to the last minute oh because
when you even just think about something
you don't like or don't want to do it
activates the insular cortex the portion
of the brain that experiences pain so
the brain naturally enough skitters away
from that thought to a new thought
that's like ooh this is so much more fun
and it'll go surfing the web or doing
whatever is more fun and you've just
procrastinated so a very powerful way of
tackling this kind of thing is to use
something called the Pramod
it was Pomodoro Commodore and that was
invented by an Italian Francesco city
low and Pomodoro is Italian for tomato
it's so simple what this does is it
sneaks your brain past that tendency to
go away from whatever is painful you
just set a timer for 25 minutes you get
rid of anything that's possibly a
distraction so no little ringy thingies
on your cell phone or that kind of thing
and no popups on your computer but then
you set that timer for 25 minutes and
you focus as intently as you can for 25
minutes realizing that we all of course
have these monkey minds and and you may
catch yourself and have to bring
yourself back but the most important
part is when you're done with the 25
minutes you relax
you reward yourself with something and
what that's doing is that's actually
allowing you to get into the diffuse
mode this more task negative relaxing
thing where you're consolidating what
you've just learned so this is a big
reason why this technique is so powerful
so and is there something magic about
the 25 minutes why not 15 minutes or 40
minutes so the magic is that remember
that pain in the brain will it goes away
after about 20 minutes so 25 minutes is
that perfect sweet spot that kind of
starts getting you in the flow and you
may even find oh wait I'm at 25 minutes
it says I should stop well sometimes I'm
in the flow so I'll just keep right on
going and that's okay if I go 25 45 two
hours whenever when I do stop I reward
myself and that helps program my brain
to enjoy the focusing process even more
it's like Pavlov with the dogs he'd he'd
ring a bell and then after a while the
dogs knew they were gonna get a reward
so they did enjoy that time in between
we're even like that as humans we can
begin enjoying that focusing period and
so make sure I understand it's not that
you have to stop at 25 minutes
just said at 25 minutes the bell rings
you have earned the right for guilt-free
whatever it might be surfing the web go
for a walk and that even that time is
still productive you shouldn't have
guilt associated with the one you did
your focus time but you're also saying
that you're getting into this the
default mode is is how you describe and
and that's where your brain if you go
for a walk you're starting to form the
connections based on what you just
focused that's right if we we often
think that way if you're relaxing and
you're not focusing that you're not
doing any work but actually your brain
is doing a lot of productive yet
subconscious work when you're taking
these breaks which is part of why these
breaks are so important and they also if
you focus focus focus all the time there
is some evidence that it might actually
reduce your creativity reduce the
ability of the default mode to kind of
kick into play so when you're taking
these little breaks you're actually also
sort of encouraging your creativity and
when the bell rings but you're in your
flow and if you're getting if you're
feeling like this is really good I'm in
the pain I mean that is fascinates
literally because I don't feel physical
pain I mean there's all sort of thing
I'm procrastinating at least 20 things
right now and I'll I don't feel pain but
you're saying it's triggering the same
part of the brain well everybody
procrastinates because when you're
working on one thing you're not working
on another aggressing but you're a
little bit different to use as a model
case for procrastination a lot of people
do but for me a only good thing for but
a lot of times you can get really you
can have a lot of good things good
options on the table and then you may
not feel that pain in the brain for me
usually there's something oh this thing
I want to work on this thing this thing
to say and I work happily away and
there's this one thing and I've been
putting it off and that's the one that
can kick in that pain in the brain sort
of feeling and it's really yeah I mean
you you definitely avoid it and it's
it's okay it's like a subconscious pain
almost but and just to finish that point
about this I'm fascinated by this you
know the Pomodoro and the the timer if
you're feeling in the flow you
have to stop you can keep going yes and
what I'll often do is I have a little
timer on my computer I'm using it I'm
working away maybe on something and and
I don't have my sound turned on on the
computer so I can always just go check
and see Oh has it expired or not and but
it doesn't actually kick me out and say
check do you want to quit now I can just
decide that you know when I feel free
but there's a lot of great apps using
the Pomodoro Technique so people like to
use these apps a lot of the time and
they'll collect Pomodoro's so forest is
a very popular app and they if you if
you complete a Pomodoro you plant a tree
if you don't you kill a tree but that
you can come collect like two to three
Pomodoro's on a certain topic another
number on another topic if you like if
you're sort of if that helps your
productivity it's a great approach for
me I generally just love to work so I'm
working away but occasionally I will
find myself surfing the web there's this
one thing I should be doing so I set the
timer and get going with the Pomodoro
and I can feel it now my brain is
trained as soon as I set that timer I
start kind of working away and actually
getting excited about even stuff I don't
like it's it's a great technique and
there might be skeptics out there says
ok you know professor Oakley she's
saying it but she's a fancy professor
you said you know my brain might be
wired differently and but yeah they
might say your brain is probably wired
differently you're a professor you've
done has this but always you know has
how is learning been for you most of
your life well before talk about that I
should mention so I teach a very large
course called learning how to learn with
Terry Sandusky on learning and and I
have to say that out of two and a half
million students it almost seems
sometimes like I've heard from them all
and they love the Pomodoro Technique so
it is so I've just got a lot of feedback
it really helps for everybody not just
people like me but people like me well
my own background is I hated math and
science when I was growing up I flunked
my way through elementary middle and
high school math and science I just
didn't have the math gene no I couldn't
do it and and then when I was 26 years
old I was getting out of the military
and you know for some weird reason
nobody wanted to get me with my Slavic
languages and literature degree and I
thought maybe I should see if I can
learn something new like maybe even this
math stuff because I could see the
officers I've worked with work they had
great job opportunities they were often
West Point engineers and so I just I
started and see I wish there had been
Khan Academy back then but I started
with remedial high school algebra and
started working my way up and now I mean
it worked I'm a professor of engineering
but if you use some of these ideas about
learning I found that the way I learned
Russian language institute is actually
very similar to how you learn in math
and science and when I applied those
same techniques which are actually the
techniques that involved how your brain
really learns it worked but if I'd known
then what I know now about learning I
still could have made it much easier so
after the military you you went on this
wine to go back into the math but at
that time you did not know about these
techniques you just what was different
about it when you were learning it in
your in your 20s versus when you first
tried to learn it when you were 14 or 15
I didn't have to have a job when I was
14 or 15 because I was supported by my
parents there was an urgency to it there
was a high stakes and it and I think
part of it too is I looked at the future
and I thought you know it's we know
language and culture is always gonna be
really important but in today's world
math and science is really important as
well and it's not like you
become an engineer or a computer
scientist but if you have some knowledge
of those fields it really broadens your
ability to get decent jobs today so I
always say yeah I did the thing
everybody told me I my passion I learned
a language but I didn't broaden my
passion and that left me in a box and so
today I often encourage people to it's
great to follow your passion but broaden
it also and you'll find that it's really
helpful in today's working world and and
how did you so you you went back into
math motivated to some degree by
economics and you it seems like you
learned it how did you fall into this
area of research when you went back to
grad school did you say I want you know
this learning is interesting to me
because it there's a phase in my life
where I had trouble and now I figured it
out or did you how did you get to this
field which is a fascinating one I think
it applies to everyone what was the
trigger that got you interested oh good
question
so I did kind of just think around a lot
in my life I mean I was in the military
as enlisted in an officer I worked at
the South Pole Station in Antarctica and
wouldn't categorize that as dinking
around that seems well it's kind of
hardcore dinking I guess yes that's
quite impressive dinking and I used to
work as a translator for the you know
for the Russians on Soviet trawlers up
in the Bering Sea
but in all of these kinds of things
um now see there's one problem though
see I'm not like you you have this
incredible working memory my working
memory is like one thing at a time
and when I get on I get it it's like
social shiny and and then I get
distracted we are more similar than you
imagine so what was the question again
for real oh yeah no that was how did you
get interested maybe I do have slightly
longer working memory if that was for
real
but how did you get interested in this
field well it just a student asked a
question and said he found out because I
was just a typical professor and you
know what maybe with a little bit lower
working memory than many professors but
I did my engineering research and so
forth and one day but I'd love to write
and so on the side I write but I keep it
hidden because tenure and all that kind
of stuff so so but one day a student
asked me how he found out I was terrible
at math growing up and said you know
how'd you do it how'd you change your
brain and I thought how did I change my
brain and I wrote him a little email and
then I thought well because of the past
books I've written I a news a little
about neuroscience about cognitive
psychology and I thought well why don't
you put together some of these ideas
because a lot of information that's out
there on learning comes from education
or some from the field of cognitive
psychology but there's actually all this
incredible research that's being done in
the field of neuroscience and so so I I
put together a manuscript and that
became the book a mind for numbers and I
just kind of wrote a book about it and
it turned out really super popular and
so I was just surprised because it was
kind of a little side just venture for
me because I just thought I was gonna do
my normal engineering stuff and then
people really liked it was a very fresh
approach I think to learning that
brought in a lot of times what there's
great great information about how to
learn effectively but it really only
encompasses a small portion of what is
truly needed to know how to learn
effectively so so for example you find
these great books in cognitive
psychology and they don't even mention
that procrastination is like the number
one issue for students and how do you
tackle that and it there's just so much
information that's that's not being put
together and so
so I'd like to synthesize and stand on
the shoulders of these great researchers
but bring in a lot of different ideas
and so that's I just kind of backed into
it accidentally because it is
fascinating because there is all this
research going on that I actually had no
idea about until starting to look at
some of your work and it is so practical
and it is so relevant to frankly
everyone but no one was really
communicating or maybe communicating it
in the right way why isn't this part of
you know why isn't every orientation at
every school and college and workplace
start off with these techniques because
it seems like it's not just school it
seems like even in the workplace you
know there's I got to get that memo out
to my coworker by Wednesday I go I'll do
it Tuesday night why isn't this more
widespread in your sense I think that
it's it's really only in the last 10
years or so that we have gotten a good
understanding of how the brain works are
a better understanding there's still a
long way to go and it hasn't caught up
with modern pedagogy and so if you asked
let's say you asked someone to create an
online course on how how do you learn
effectively or yes some University a
major university to produce such a
course they said great we'll do it for
teachers and if she said no actually
normal people ordinary people would like
to know this tooth they'd say good will
produce a course and it will have two
weeks on the history of Education two
more weeks on theories of Education two
more weeks on how babies learn a little
bit on how people learn it but no
neuroscience maybe just one lecture cuz
it's too hard
and so what Terri and I did was kind of
flip that on its head and say well let's
start from neuroscience if it's too
advanced we'll use some metaphors to
help bring you along and it actually is
easy stuff and it's so useful and that's
why the learning order learned course is
so incredibly popular it's it's simple
and easy kinds of information but I
think some of it too is let's say you
are a professor of cognitive psychology
and you've just spent the last 30 years
of your life researching issues related
to working memory
you know there's part of you that
screams it can't be that easy I've been
working forever on this thing and she's
making it just like but it actually is
the fundamental ideas are really really
easy for anybody to understand and so
I've been working with Terry and and
Greg Hammonds to make some great videos
for kids now that that also explains
some of these ideas because everybody
says these ideas about learning are so
simple that anybody can learn I mean I
wish I had known them when I was a kid
actually that's true so that's what
we've been working on yeah it's it's
it's so surprising because one they they
seem they make intuitive sense but then
when you back it up with the
neuroscience then it are they're
skeptics here it feels like you know you
could say the sky is blue and there will
be skeptics there will be someone who
will say what are other people said well
no that's not exactly right you know
sometimes it's better to pull an
all-nighter I don't know whoa are you
hearing pushback from any one no I mean
every great once a while you get put
anybody will get pushback but when
you're working with one of the world's
greatest neuroscientists all I kind of
have to do is say okay you want to argue
about the neuroscience go talk to this
guy
and Terry is is really one of the world
leaders but I think if you use a
metaphorical approach to explain some of
these fundamental ideas and you say I'm
using a metaphor this is the main idea
it's kind of hard to argue with that and
going back to the the very practical
tips I guess you could say you know we
talked about this importance of sleep
would you say that it's is there any
research or even rules of thumb about
maybe the best time to study is morning
evening or is that kind of the the
jury's out on that jury's out because
some people love some people of morning
people others or night owls they do find
that as you as the day goes by your
metabolites will come out and you're
getting accumulated
in toxins but even so some people just
be it seem to be able to perform better
at night and so you know blossom they I
wish I could be that way
but there's just everyone's different we
do find that there's about four hours or
so of really intense sort of time you
can do deliberate practice and and do
something that's really hard so for
example if you're a concert pianist
about four hours is your best practice
time mathematician or whatever but you
can still get a lot done sleep though
there do seem to be a few people that
have this short sleep gene that can get
by on three or four hours of sleep I
want that gene can they maybe you know
introduce it somehow but for most people
you need around eight hours or so
younger people need more sleep naps can
help but they can't really replace a
good solid block of sleep at night it's
interesting as connected to Khan Academy
this for our number that you mentioned
it definitely syncs with my personal
experience cuz when I make videos videos
are actually quite mentally taxing to do
because most of them they're done in
real time so you're trying to do the
problem in real time but at the same
time there's a part of your brain that's
making sure are you saying all the right
things would this be understandable for
someone are you speaking cohesive you
know all of these types of things and
since I've started this journey on Khan
Academy about four hours is my cap after
four hours I really can't produce more
and then I try to do you know less
mentally intensive things but it's it is
amazing I kind of just hit a wall after
about four hours yep I find that myself
and so people say well then we should
only have four hours in the work day and
yeah I wish but but actually four hours
are really intense and then the other
hours as you can still be very
productive just doing things that are a
little less intellectually demanding
yeah and my old boss and I didn't
realize his advice was based in sound to
neuroscience but even when I work
hedge-fund and you know finance and
hedge funds they're normally associate
with people working 80 hours a week and
always on and all this he was very
adamant that as soon as the the markets
closed that you know we were in Boston
at 4:30 when we were out in California
was at 1:30
he said go home recharge make sure you
get a night's sleep because our whole
job is to make good decisions and to
avoid bad ones and as soon as you but I
think he's also implicitly saying that
look you've been studying all these
stocks and doing all this analysis all
day part of it is let those let that
default mode happen and so you might
start seeing some insights I think
that's very true it's very good advice I
think another piece of advice that I
give and I don't I don't know that
there's actually neuroscience based on
this but is to try during your recharge
hours to learn about something that's
completely unrelated to whatever your
main taskings and I think what that does
is that allows you to think more
creatively let's say that you're trying
to really learn about investing so you
read all the books about investing well
you're actually reading all the same
books about investing that everybody
else is reading if you if you are
learning something completely different
just a tiny bit of the time you will
bring through metaphor and analogy
creative new ideas and new approaches to
whatever you're learning about that's
fascinating cuz I you know that you see
this pattern in people's lives that when
they're school-aged they're studying
multiple subjects but then as soon as
they get into their field of specialty
they start only reading or doing in that
field of specialty and what you're
suggesting and it does seem right I am
curious maybe someone will do research
on this eventually that you might be
doing yourself the best service do that
for hours maybe do three hours of the
thing that you have to do in the next
week or whatever the next year but then
maybe give yourself some time to do
something completely different don't
feel bad about it it might actually be
forming connections that you don't even
appreciate that's exactly right I
couldn't agree more
well oh I I have many more questions but
I want to open it up to those of y'all
in the audience
any questions yes Julia
you talk about how during the course of
your life like they say a young child
can learn a language and repent repeat
the question just for folks so does your
brain slow down when you're older and
can you still learn languages and so
forth and the answer is yeah there's a
little evidence that you slow down and
part of the reason you slow down is you
have so many more connections that it's
kind of hard to do the search and
accessing of what you're trying to to
remember and learn and so forth
it is there's only a certain window when
you can learn a language with an
appropriate accent but you can still
learn a language in fact there is plenty
of examples there's a whole language
learner ecosystem with some terrific
individuals Benny the Irish polyglot for
example who who will introduce you to
people who are even in their 60s and 70s
and are learning new languages but have
you ever met those kinds of really
they're older people and they're kind of
curmudgeons and they they think their
way is right no matter what you don't
want to be like that person so the best
way to avoid that is to keep your keep
learning keep your mind open to new
things and so I think these are the
kinds of things you make available to
everyone in a way that whatever level
you're at you can start there and then
move upwards and so many different I I
have to admit I used your videos to help
improve my statistics course because
yeah it's such a great approach for kind
of weaving in different ideas about
what's on and binomial and how they're
related and then my younger daughter
said the reason I passed calculus and
she did very well was because of Khan
Academy's videos
you've done some great work thank you
I'm flattered in a team effort and
you're making a brown man blush so
congratulations no but look I I will
also admit I also use Khan Academy tutor
because I think my working memory is
shorter than you give me credit for but
no no it is everyone has to relearn and
review and I actually met a Nobel Prize
winner in economics who said that he was
using the Khan Academy videos to refresh
on certain parts of economics because he
had gotten so deep in his specialty that
when he had to review some more of the
basic ideas it was a good refresher so
there's no shame no shame in that that's
right I think that's the that's what I
love about the Khan Academy approaches
when you have those gaps and everybody's
got those gaps you if you're climbing
higher in that particular subject matter
you can go and fill in those gaps so
much more easily with the videos that
are available and we have thousands of
practice items to this my little plug
but yes that's a yes I could test their
knowledge yes all right could you share
more about what are some of the concepts
behind and learning how to learn okay so
we've talked about focused and diffuse
and then there's also an the Pomodoro
Technique creating sets of links of
neural links and practicing with those
sets of neural links so that you you
build stronger sets what that does is
see what is an example of that what does
it mean to practice with sets of neural
links okay I'll give so for example mmm
when our younger daughter was learning
to back up the car she was I mean it was
really really hard for her and I mean it
is hard for anybody do you look in the
front mirrored you look in the side
maersk you look behind you which way do
you go and then you're off in the ditch
so what is happening is you have a very
limited working memory that can hold
usually a maximum around four items and
so what
you're trying to kind of hold all these
concepts at once and it's difficult but
once you have learned to back up a car
so you've learned it you practice with
it you really know it what you've done
is you've kind of parked this new set of
long-term links in or of links in your
long-term memory and what's happening
with your working memory is it's going
oh I want to backup the car well I've
only got four arms that I can work with
well I already know how to do this I'm
just gonna reach out to this out this
subroutine that I parked out in
long-term memory I'll grab that pull
that into my working memory and oh yes
while I'm doing that my other arms of my
my attentional octopus are free so I can
be listening to the radio maybe checking
to see if my seat belt is fashion
fastened and this is what happens in a
lot of learning if you have practiced
and created this nice set of neural
links then what what happens when you're
taking a test is you take the test and
there go you go well now wait a minute
now they want me to put binomial
distribution together with a geometric
there being a little tricky here but you
can hold them both up in the working
memory because you've got these nice
sort of procedural fluency sets of links
you've already set up so you can just
connect them in the limited working
memory that you do have so the more you
experts are there differentiated from
normal you non-experts
by the fact that they have all sorts of
sets of neural links that they've
created and parked in long-term memory
and they can access them and bring them
up into working memory whenever they
want to and so that is such an important
part of learning we often just think
well you should conceptually understand
this idea so you should pull it all into
working memory and really have it all in
mind but our working memory is really
restricted you can't have it all in mind
so you want to have practice enough so
that important parts of what you're
learning are already parked that
you know in your long-term memory and
this is let's say you're learning to
play a musical instrument so you learn a
chord and then you get that part in
long-term memory now you connect that up
with another chord and maybe another and
then suddenly you can play part of a
song and if you practice enough you can
just get it started and it'll play on
its own actually that's another story
but but same for learning a language if
you're learning and you practice with
the different conjugation verb
conjugations it becomes very natural
very automatic and so really the
important a really important part of
learning is creating these nice sets of
long-term memory links that you can just
instantly pull into working memory
whenever you need to so where would
those be the kind of the the headline
concepts that you talked about so as a
focused and the was the default default
mode Network so sometimes I call it
defuse defuse so focus and defuse right
the Pomodoro and then this idea of
getting things in I like that kind of
these meant to mental tentacles the
extra arms that we can build through
practice by reinforcing those networks
as much as we can right so working
memories in your your prefrontal cortex
and it can connect into the long-term
sets of links that you've created there
so that's another really important thing
if so here's often we think that
students best traits are really bad
traits and what I mean by this is
sometimes will think oh well you've got
a poor working memory that's really bad
but actually I am here to tell you and
it's not just self-justification that
having a poor working memory can
actually be a really good thing and the
reason for that is remember those
forearms of that attentional octopus in
your working memory well some people are
just they have really retentive working
memories and other people are
like me you know there they got it it's
all in my Oh shiny and then if something
falls out but when something falls out
something else comes in and research has
shown that individuals that have
problems with their working memory are
often very creative and indeed my hero
in science is a man named Santiago Ramon
y Cajal and he kaha was a terrible
student awful working memory couldn't
really retain stuff very easily was a
troubled student got kicked out of
school several times and ended up
winning the Nobel Prize and he's now
considered the father of modern
neuroscience and qahal was once asked
how'd you do it
I mean you what's your secret that can
help us and he said I am no genius and
he wasn't he really struggled to try to
learn something new but he said I was
successful because I was persistent and
I was flexible when the data told me I
was wrong he said I've worked with many
geniuses and the challenge with geniuses
as they can be so smart they get used to
always being right and then in adult
life they can tend to jump to
conclusions without having all the data
and when they're wrong they aren't used
to being wrong so they can't change
their mind instead they'll use their
considerable intellect to justify what
give whatever they've been wrong at so I
said I think the real point here is if
you're one of those slower thinkers that
really come ask to struggle
congratulations you can sometimes do
things even geniuses cannot and that
makes you question the whole title of
genius because obviously by most
definitions the gentleman you just spoke
of would be but it's just on the
traditional you know he can't memorize
dictionaries and whatever else but
clearly he made insights that weren't
available to others and that flexibility
is a form of Jesus genius you know
itself I think so yeah
other questions yes I I notice you
sprinkle a lot of humor in your videos
and I was wondering if you can say a few
words about the role of humor in
learning oh so that the challenge for me
is I'm not very funny
so I I like have to script it so
carefully because it just doesn't
necessarily come naturally this one
fifth grader was taking our course and
she said I never understood that
professors could be so witty and I'm
like I scripted that witty in you did
you do reading a script right now no
I've just prepared that very capable but
so it's making the point that you were
you're overly self-deprecating you're
clearly are witty without a script at
all look at continue your story Wow I've
heard it for the maestro but but I think
that people a lot of times university
professors they it is hard to be funny I
mean some people are funny naturally and
it just that's the way they are but a
lot of people it it's it doesn't come
naturally and so it's not something that
they when they're teaching they would
prefer to just teach the topic and not
also have to worry about humor and you
can understand that but the online world
I think of it as a mixture of academia
with Silicon Valley with Hollywood and
if you're gonna be really competitive on
the online world it's not like
universities you know it's not like
grandma's university anymore it's it's
something that you've got to be
competitive with everything else it's
going out there if you have quality
material and if you have a course that's
just you know a stayed presentation of
the material versus a course that
presents the same material but it's got
some nice humor in it people are gonna
pick the the funny course every time so
I think that simply hasn't received
enough attention from research and mood
makers and I think it's such an it being
funny even when it's hard is important
because it helps people to connect
who the instructor is and to have more
fun with the material just as the
instructor is doing well would the point
you're bringing is an interesting one
because you're you're kind of making a
market-based argument that people will
be drawn to the the funnier courses but
I do suspect that I'm curious if
neuroscience has even come up with
anything or it should be an area of
study in the intuition would be if
people are able to laugh a little bit it
de-stresses them it opens their mind up
so that they're less likely to be
stressed as the new informations coming
in which is actually might lead to
better learning but it is interesting
humor is such a big thing in our society
it's such a big thing of what makes us
us but it doesn't seem to be that
studied it's not there there's a very
good paper I believe from 2015 that's a
meta analysis of humor studies and
actually it kind of concluded the
verdict is out as to whether humor is
helpful and I think part of that is just
like a very non funny study it sounds
not much fun to read but one of the
things I think they make the mistake of
looking at a particular topic and saying
okay we've got five minutes of funny and
five minutes of non funny you know a
little bit of humor or no humor but
that's the wrong way to look at humor
you can't dissect it into a topic it's a
course does that does it uplift people's
affect through the course and and that
really has not been studied an attitude
it's a talk and I wonder I mean it I
know we're going a little off topic but
just from an evolutionary biology point
of view where humor and laughing it's
funny cuz you know an alien would might
be afraid if we're burying our teeth and
we're going you know it's almost seems
threatening but we view it as a somehow
it's crept into who we are as as
organisms and it seems to be at least
you know some of our related organisms
at least seem to relate to it but it is
fascinating it is I should say there's
there's been a little bit of research on
two full courses and so forth but
there's a lot from a neuroscientific
perspective there's a lot of similarity
between the haha
creative insight and the ah you're
starting to laugh about something
there's a lot of neural overlap there so
I think you're right when you say that
it relaxes people and we tend to think
of default mode Network is only a rising
like when you take a few minutes a break
and so forth but actually default mode
Network can arise just momentarily even
when you blink in fact martial arts
experts like to launch attacks when you
blink not because you're not looking so
much as your brain is temporarily
disconnected from the outside world and
you go into default mode during that
blink and and so then even when you're I
think when you're learning something and
you take that tiny aha laughing break my
suspicion and I haven't seen research
evidence to this effect is you totally
go into default mode and it is it's
you're able to come back and look at
things with a fresh perspective as a
result I now understand why my offensive
charges in the past weren't as
successful I was i timed them wrong and
there we go there are other other
questions yeah actually we have some
questions over here from students so one
of the main problems I have is that I'm
not good at starting something that I
don't like to do such as math and do you
have any advice on starting something
you just haven't been able to start
before cuz you think it's gonna take a
really long time
oh that I so sympathize with you because
I hated math for so long and the thing
for me is you hate a topic until you
start getting traction with it you get
better at it and if an math can take a
little while to get better at so I just
go the completely different way I'm like
use the Pomodoro Technique it's it means
a tiny bit of something you don't like
25 minutes is in the greater scheme of
things anybody can do 25 minutes so when
you're sitting down don't sit there and
go I'm gonna do my
yeah and what that's doing is activating
the paint say I'm sitting down to do a
Pomodoro and that tricks your brain so
you don't experience the pain quite so
much and then just oh I gotta get my 25
minutes now if you're like me I will sit
there sometimes and I something I don't
want to do I really work you know I set
the timer I'm on the Pomodoro I'm
working away and you know and I can't
help I look up because I'm kind of proud
of myself how much work I've done and
I've just done two minutes of the
Pomodoro and my mind screams I can't do
23 more minutes but then I just do the
same thing I let that thought flow right
on by and I continue working for the 25
and then I give myself a nice reward
maybe you listen to my favorite song go
to a computer game whatever you know you
want to do and I think if you try this
approach it might be very helpful for
you huh as a student I don't always like
get to decide when my classes are I like
when my breaks are so how can I really
implement the Pomodoro Technique when
I'm in my classes or in my goal time
trying to get work done
oh okay so the Pomodoro Technique kind
of presumes that you've got 25 minutes
available to do that and you block
everything else out so what you want to
do is if you have self directed time
available whatever that time is just put
away all distractions and try to work
with as much focus as you can on that
topic during that time that you have
available so so 25 minutes is great it's
kind of optimal in a way but whatever
you do have one of the core ideas of the
Pomodoro is to not allow yourself to be
distracted by other things because if
let's say you're listening to songs with
music in it it can be okay to listen to
music if as long as it's not loud and as
long as it doesn't have lyrics in it if
it has some
singing you're part of your working
memory is going to be following along
with those words and if you're doing
something writing in writing or reading
something it can interfere because
you've got that limited working memory
so it's a it's a really good thing to
just do the Pomodoro or do that that
period of time and try to block
everything out that you can don't be
switching tasks in other words oh I'm
doing this for two minutes oh now I got
to do that well oh and I'm doing this
sometimes you'll have to because of you
know what's being taught but as much as
you can try to keep your focus because
the longer you're on there the kind of
the deeper it's like you're you're
building these networks this connection
you're bringing it all to mind and you
want to just you know keep that without
multitasking because if you're going to
another task it's like you're ripping
out of those neurons and now you're
going to another set of neurons and then
you got to go back to that set of
original neurons and that can be really
tiring
so hopefully this might help is there we
talked about the 25 minutes we don't
want to get too prescriptive but is
there kind of a sense of how long the
defuse times is there a ratio that
people think is good this is not studied
enough what I just hear anecdotally is
if you have a fair bit of work to do
then maybe five to ten minutes something
like that if you have trouble getting
yourself back on task after you're
taking a break set a timer for the break
some people like to have a timer that's
a ticking timer when they're doing their
Pomodoro because it helps remind them to
keep on task for me I I like silence
when I'm doing it but five to ten
minutes and then after you've done
several in a row then maybe take a
15-minute break 25 minutes on five to
ten minutes off it would speak to Chris
Shawn's question you know we have a lab
school downstairs and one of the goals
of it is to think about what school
should be like and so even this
technique and you know we already have a
principal around as much active learning
as possible versus passive learning but
even that active learning
you know we might have to get everyone
timers or something to think about how
to do this at followed by maybe 10 15
minute breaks could be really
interesting and and I had to point out
when it comes to active learning there's
a large meta-analysis that was done of
stem learning and what they found was
that one in three students would drop
out of STEM program science technology
engineering and math if it was just the
traditionally taught but only one in
five would drop out if it was active
learning and part of what's going on I
think of it and I think there's some
truth to this is when you're active
learning
you're not just passively watching
someone or you are in some sense like
here's your your dendrite now on your
neuron you are almost pulling a
dendritic spine to start coming out and
making a little connection and that's
what active that's almost I think maybe
studies will show this will see but
that's almost why when you're really
working on something hard with
deliberate practice it almost hurts now
so I can relate this to why I cannot
play the piano today and so when my
parents wanted me to play the piano so
so I found out though I was not a dumb
kid I found out that as long as they
were hearing music come out they didn't
mind would it whatever I was doing so I
learned a song and I would I played that
song over and over I put a comic book up
and I could just play that song over and
over for an hour while I was reading my
comic book and I could read my comic
books that's actually quite impressive
if you learn a song really well but did
I advance in my studies no I didn't
because I wasn't doing deliberate
practice I wasn't like pushing myself
beyond and so so that is the essence of
why deliberate practice kind of focusing
on the harder stuff it a little bit out
of your comfort zone stretching you a
little bit zone of proximal development
yes
locks on whatever people call it you did
not do that I did not do that and now I
cannot play the piano you do what many
other things very well other maybe we
have time for one or two more questions
yeah I had a quick question there's this
phrase it's like riding a bike and
something that you haven't done for a
while but I've learned you might be able
to pick that up very quickly that
doesn't seem to be the case for all
things that one learns so I was
wondering is it to do with the learning
the activity type or what is it to
actually increase retention of things
that you've already learned that's a
very good question it from an
evolutionary perspective we think of
what we learn it actually there's two
different types of things that we learn
and one is like evolutionarily primary
and that is things like learning to
speak a language and so forth well
evolutionarily secondary learning are
things like learning to read learning
learning how to to write and sew and
learning how to do math those come with
more difficulty and that is why a lot of
times teachers with great intent will
say Oh learning should always be as fun
when you're in high school as it was
when you were a little kid a baby and so
forth well that's when you were learning
things that came naturally to human
beings like speaking a language your
native language and so I think that when
you're when you're learning something I
it depends a lot on whether it's a
primary or a secondary type of learning
thing and it also depends it there's a
it's a really complicated subject so for
example if I try to learn Spanish now I
learned Russian before and it will come
out sometimes in Russian whether I like
it or not and if I have a little bit of
what go it comes the Russian comes back
even more easily so odd kind
particularly like vodka in particularly
in vodka from the freezer properly so
not advocating anything
that's for sure uh but it is funny how
the environmental cues that you had can
also be and so I unfortunately I think
we're all out of time but thank you so
much for this I think for everyone
watching for all of us here at Khan
Academy I think personally we're all
gonna maybe get some timers or use some
of these apps but I think it really does
it is very tangibly useful to have some
of these frameworks and I think as we
think about Khan Academy even the
product and the experiences we think
about how we do practice on Khan Academy
and all these things I think it'll be
really valuable for us to say it maybe
some of these ideas that we learned from
Professor Oakley will be a could make a
big difference here so thank you so much
and for all of y'all erasers to do a web
search for professor Barbara Oakley
you'll see all sorts of investment
[Applause]